president trump's son eric is in las  vegas tonight as well he hosted a  latinos for trump event at the ahern  hotel  that event was held with famous ufc  fighter tito ortiz  topics ranging from the stimulus package  to getting out the vote  i'm really proud of my father he's put  together you know three stimulus  packages and there's gonna be another  one the democrats are holding it up  because they don't want  a stimulus package before the election  they think that would help my father in  some way shape or form  i know we're gonna win i know we're  gonna win and i really believe we're  gonna win the state people have to get  out and vote  but i really believe we're going to win  this great state  prior to tonight's event at the ahern  eric trump was in reno where he held a  make america great again rally  he is off to ohio on wednesday